your thoughts on collaboration um
yeah i would say that that the biggest
thing christine and i have learned
recently is
is the value of a good partnership or
partnerships
if you want to make a documentary film
for example
it's really difficult to make that all
by yourself
um they take a long time to make they
usually take quite a bit of money um you
know it's it's almost like running an
ultra marathon with with one one foot
instead of two i mean you really have to
have
you have to have partners um
and the partnerships don't necessarily
have to be
financial partnerships um if you can
find if you look you know if you're
making a film
that is telling a a very
specific story like on our current film
we made a
we made our current film if you build it
is a year in the life of one of
america's most innovative classrooms
well there's a lot of groups
around education around design and
architecture which is a big theme in our
film
rural development
sustainable business models et cetera et
cetera i mean there's a lot of people in
that space
so it's really important to understand
the story you're telling and then to be
able to explain to people
the story that you're telling because if
there's a really good fit
then you're bringing something really
valuable to the table
you're you're about to make a movie that
illustrates the mission that this
non-profit is on or this
foundation or this whatever
and you should partner up i think the
biggest pitfall that
partnerships fall into is they get
all lawyered up up front and they they
do these
very thick um very onerous kinds of
agreements with each other i mean
i would never go into a partnership with
anybody
if we couldn't put our terms down on one
sheet of paper
in plain english i i think it's
important
if you're doing a partnership to have a
clear understanding
of what each other wants i think it's
important also
it may be important in some cases to
go into a formal sort of contract
agreement
but keep it simple somebody hands me a
42 page contract there's no way i'm
first of all i'm not going to read it
second of all i'm not going to sign it
and third one i'm going to move on
because that's not a partner i want to
get into bed with on a project what does
that say about someone
they got you know their priorities i
think in the wrong place
somebody somebody hands me somebody
hands me a contract that's
that thick and we've had some that were
really tricky and
created lots of problems um
i think what happens is if you're if you
get a contract like that
you're dealing with someone or a group
that doesn't
understand the creative process
um if i'm making a movie
and you want to help me make that movie
and we there's an overlap between
what i'm doing and what you're doing you
should be able to put that down on a
piece of paper
in 100 words or less and figure out if
there's a good fit
and then move forward you should also
give yourself an out
if this doesn't work for whatever reason
i'm out
if you don't hold up your end of the
bargain i'm out you know
it's i mean these films are the budgets
on these documentaries are so tight
that you cannot really afford
to spend a lot of money on contracts
and i think for some reason people do
that we have an amazing lawyer
named lisa calif she's one of the best
attorneys working in in non-fiction and
we work with her all the time
but i think she would also agree that
these kinds of partnerships
i think the best kinds of partnerships
that i've had in my career are handshake
partnerships
it's not 10 lawyers on each side
partnerships those are usually not
very successful well you had said
earlier
you have this thing amongst your group
that the best idea wins yeah so then
when you have this
huge agreement it almost sounds like
it's so much control
from the other party that that's not
going to be open you can't even
understand what you're
what you're agreeing to so yeah i think
that's really kind of a problem
so that's a red flag yeah yeah because i
think it's hard to know
you know up front unless you've known
these people for years and you've
mentioned people that you've known for
years and you trust them
but for someone who's new they're not
going to know and there's not you know
sometimes there's there's red flags that
you
you go back to and you look at later and
you say okay i realized that that was
probably
a sign right there that i should have
said this isn't going to work well like
i said when you if you if you are
if you are going to sign a contract with
someone who's a partner or
can i help you make a project let's say
um what's your out clause
how do you get out right because if you
don't have an out clause then you're
you know it might become like prison
like you're stuck and you can't get out
um so you really have to understand that
um
and and again like
i think for the filmmakers who are
watching
um you know you should you should
understand that
that of all the people on the team
the filmmakers are going to spend
way more time and energy telling the
story
than the financiers the broadcast
partners
the non-profits you name it
and so you should be confident in
knowing that
whatever is important to you in order to
tell the story
is important and you should also be
confident in your ability because
if you're in a room with nine other
partners and they all have certain needs
and wants
but you're the filmmaker you're the most
important
member of that partnership the movie
cannot be made without you
so know that going in and
be confident in what your contribution
is going to be
and also to the subject you may have
said that and i just
yeah i mean the subject the subject i
think
the subjects are very much our partners
in what we do
and you know you do form a partnership
with the people who are in your films
not not a financial partnership we've
never paid anyone in our to appear in
our films
nor will we ever do that i think that's
i think that
creates a can create a real problem
but in the same way that i wouldn't hand
one of our subjects
a really thick release form
i wouldn't want one of my partners to
hand that to me either
i want to be able to have a conversation
about what we're all trying to
achieve and and then go from there
it's hey that's a better way to start
it's a little bit like
you know on your first date you're doing
blood tests and
talking about what you're going to wear
at your wedding and credit checks it's
like well wait a minute we're not there
yet
you